okay here we're going to link between
Mersenne primes and perfect numbers I
think we're getting it well I'm going to
prove that link so here's how we're
going to do it we're going to once again
we're going to have N and we're going to
have 2 to the N minus 1 but I'm not
going to bother with the ones that don't
work I'm only going to have the ones
that work which is 2 3 5 7 and 13 and
they give us the Mersenne primes 2 gives
us 3 3 gives us 7 5 gives us 31 127 8191
and then they match up with some perfect
numbers which I'm going to put over here
as perfect number and so 3 matches up
with 6 7 matches up with 28 31 matches
up with 496 127 matches up with 8,000
128 and then this one matches up with
something we will get to that in a
second can there only be one Mersenne
prime among the factors of a perfect
number yes there is out there there is
only ever one Mersenne Prime in the
factors of an even perfect number and
every even perfect number has one
Mersenne Prime in there somewhere the
reason I keep saying even and I'm going
to stop saying even from now on is
because no one has ever found an odd
perfect number but no one has ever
managed to prove that odd perfect
numbers don't exist so for all we know
it could be an odd perfect number but no
one's come across it we do know if we
find an odd perfect number it's not
going to have a Mersenne prime as a
factor so from now on lastly a perfect
number I mean even perfect number by
default so if you look at the link I
showed you that these were all factors
of these perfect numbers in fact I'm
going to write those in so if you have 3
you multiply it by 2 you get 6 if you
get 7 and you multiply it by 4 you get
28 if you get 31 you multiply it by 16
you get 400 600 7 x 64 you get 8,000 128
and so now you should be thinking what's
the pattern here right because let's say
I give you a new Mersenne prime so I've
given you this let's say is
hot-off-the-press I say wow I've just
found 8101 is a Mersenne prime you're
like well I want to know what it's
perfect number is because that's where
the fun is
get Mersenne Prime's in fact Mersenne
primes were first studied by the ancient
Greeks solely to get to the perfect
number goodness and so all we want to
know is what do I have to multiply that
by to get over there and so people
search for all sorts of patterns people
go up it's obvious because if you square
2 you get 4 u square 4 you get 16 that's
the pattern ignoring the fact that 16
squared is 256 and the people got all
the weight your ma divided by 4 because
4 times 4 is 16 sticking is my 4 is 64
and they ignore the fact that 2 by 4 is
not for writes people find other pans
the actual pattern is this equals 2 to
the 1 that equals 2 squared that equals
2 to the 4 that equals 2 to the 6 and
it's these numbers here the 1 the 2 the
4 and the 6 that's where the pattern is
that is always 1 less than the number
over here so 1 less than 2 that's our 1
1 lesson 3 that's our 2 1 less than 5
that's our 4 1 less than 7 that's our 6
and so this column is 2 to the N minus 1
I reckon if you've given me 2 weeks I
wouldn't figure that out so I use this
to torment young people I get high
school students to try and work out that
pattern and basically I walk around
being a professional jerk because I
won't give them the answer and they're
come up with a pattern I go what does it
work and they'll try the next one and it
won't and eventually one can work it out
and they will be the most smug child you
have ever met and justifiably so
and they will happily retire convinced
that if you have a Mersenne Prime 2 to
the N minus 1 and you then multiply that
by 2 to the N minus 1 you always always
always get a perfect number and then
they will go home and I will say well
how do we not works how do we know
that's always going to work we have we
haven't proven that and and they will
confuse trying examples with proving
something and I love trying example and
I want to rain hate on the trying
example parade because that's how you
find patterns to start with but you then
got to prove them so we're going to
prove that
this always works and if you're very
careful by the way because 2 to the N
minus 1 sounds a lot like 2 to the N
minus 1 and this negative this subtract
1 can drift if you're not careful when
you're copying things but what's quite
fun if you get someone to do this listen
to how they pronounce this because
people pronounce super scripts in maths
with rising inflections and so you get
kids to read this out they go well this
is 2 to the N minus 1 times 2 to the N
minus 1 and that's you know that means
superscript so again we're aliens and
that's why I strains are very good at
math so that's why I put this at the end
right so I end on the inflection and put
at the beginning that messes with I
can't do 2 to the N minus 1 2 to the N
minus 1 just met this does that's not as
much fun so we're going to prove this
and I'm going to prove it by doing an
example first and then I'm going to do
it in the general sense so let's be lazy
and do 496 and so a little while ago I
impressed you and possibly two or three
other people by randomly listing off as
if I had memorized them all the factors
of 496 all I was doing there starting at
1 and doubling double 1 to get to double
2 to get 4 double 4 to get 8 double 8 to
get 16 if I double 16 I get 32 which is
1 above a Mersenne prime so in fact to
get any perfect number you start at one
you keep doubling until you can choose
any Mersenne prime of your choosing
you get 1 above a Mersenne prime instead
of writing plus 32 I'm going to put plus
31 instead I'm going to switch to the
Mersenne prime and then I'm going to
continue the doubling so I double that I
get 62 I double that I got 124 I double
that I get 248 so in fact I wasn't I
hadn't memorized those numbers I just
started a doubling sequence and then
jumped off it to a mess in prime you had
when they were close you had memorized
immersed in prime I had memorized the
Mersenne Prime's and then I doubled the
Mersenne primes to finish the sequence
and because I am a color know where
we're going I'm going to switch back to
adding in the number itself which you
remember I did before I said you could
add the number but the total is twice
the original I'm going to put that back
in the mix so how could we add these up
in close if we just add them up by
summing them let's get slightly more
excited because if we look at this this
sequence here is actually that sequence
times the Mersenne prime so I could
rewrite this this equals 1 plus 2 plus 4
plus 8 plus 16 plus Mersenne Prime 31
outside 1 plus 2 plus 4 plus 8 plus 16
and that's actually why I put this back
on so we get that same 16 in there
because I can then make that 1 plus 31
because it's 1 times that sequence plus
31 times that sequence that's 1 plus 31
times 1 plus 2 plus 4 plus 8 plus 16
that's that now equals will that equals
32 and that will always bump it back up
to the next power of 2 sets come to the
5 and 1 plus 2 plus 4 plus 8 plus 16 if
you actually add them all together that
equals 4 numbers 31 and if you multiply
those together you get twice 496 you're
gonna get 992 it so that that's an
unusual way to add them together right
but now we're going to do the same thing
in general for this equation what I'm
going to do is I'm going to take 2 to
the N minus 1 times 2 to the n minus 1
and I'm going to show that if you add
all the factors of this they sum to give
you that formula or rather if you add
all the factors not just the proper
factors they sum to twice that formula
so what are the factors of that well
what have we got at the frontier we've
got 2 to the N minus 1 so that means the
factors are definitely going to be 1
plus 2 to the 1 plus 2 squared plus 2
cubed plus all the way up to go all the
way up to 2 to the N minus 1 so that's
going to be plus 2 to the N minus 2 plus
2 to the n minus 1 that's going to be
our whole run so this is obviously a big
power of 2 they're all its factors this
is prime it's not going to have any
factors but it's going to be this
multiplied by all of these so now we're
going to have this we're going to
two to the n minus one plus two to the
one outside of two to the N minus one
plus two squared outside of two to the n
minus one plus all the way up above a
bar plus two to the N minus two outside
of two to the N minus one plus two to
the N minus one outside of two to the N
minus one which is our original number
again on the end of the list just like
we had over here that's equivalent of
the same number on the very end so that
is the actual formula as appeared again
so what we really want to show is all
the other ones add to the same as that
so we're going to show that by showing
that all of them together equal twice
that okay so we can start to tidy this
up a little bit so that's going to equal
this top sequence can stay the same
that's still going to be 1 plus 2 to the
1 plus 2 squared plus all the way up
plus 2 to the N minus 2 plus 2 to the N
minus 1 and this one here I'm going to
put that out the front so that's going
to be 2 to the N minus 1 so that's that
prime number times 1 plus 2 to the 1
plus 2 squared plus Delta R plus 2 to
the N minus 2 plus 2 to the N minus 1 ok
now we're going to because we have 1 lot
of this and we have that lot of that so
that's going to equal 1 plus that but
then we've got minus 1 so that's just
going to equal 2 to the N outside of so
what I've done I've done same as over
here which was the Mersenne prime plus 1
gave us back to 2 to the 5 I've done
this plus 1 the ones canceled out I'm
just left with 2 to the N and this is
going to be 1 plus 2 to the 1 plus 2
squared plus 2 to the N minus 2 plus 2
to the N minus 1 now here's our problem
how on earth can we add together a
sequence of numbers a series here we
don't know how many the rabbit where
it's where it stops somehow we have to
add together AC because we don't know
the end but we can do that with a little
bit of cleverness where we just say
let's assume we know the total right
let's just say there is some total and
it equals whatever all of this happens
to add
we currently don't know what it is but
we've given it a name which is always
the first step in maths and again what
would be twice that total what if we had
two times that total well that would
equal double all of this so that would
then become two plus double that would
become 2 squared plus double that would
become 2 cubed plus all the way up
double that would become double that
would be to the dot plus 2 to the N
minus 1 double that plus 2 to the N and
actually that is the same as that that
tobe the same as that term all the way
down that is the same as that that is
the same as that so fact all of these
match apart from the beginning one here
and the end one here so we want to
cancel all these out if I take all of
these and subtract all of these I'll
just be left with this one subtract that
one
so 2t minus T this row minus that row
equals two to the n minus one and so
back to t minus T is just T to the total
is 2 to the N minus 1 and we call this
the geometric series so that this always
a particular case for the geometric
series where you can add together any
long list to sequence the numbers or
each one is the previous one multiplied
by a constant amount in this case we're
multiplying it by 2 each time it works
for other ratios so I can swap that in
for all this mess becomes that so now
this bring that down equals 2 to the n
outside of 2 to the n minus 1 and you're
like well we're practically there the
only thing we're missing is we expect a
minus 1 there and we haven't got it here
where's that gone well like I said this
is twice the original number so we want
to prove that this equals twice what we
started with so we go with that
equals twice times what's left if you
take out 2 well that's 2 to the N minus
outside of 2 to the n minus 1 and that's
it and so that is the proof that if you
have a Mersenne Prime 2 to the n minus 1
and you multiply it by 2 to the N minus
1 you're guaranteed to get a perfect
number
because if you take all the factors of
that expression and then you add them
all together you get back to twice the
original expression which is our
definition of the perfect number and so
people talk about the fact that there's
a link between Mersenne primes and
perfect numbers but now we have managed
to prove it that's I'm so pleased I'm
going to put the lids back on to both of
the pins hi there everyone it's Brady
who makes the numberphile videos and I'm
actually starting a new channel in
January 2015 called objectivity and it's
all about all the amazing treasures and
science objects you find in places like
this the archive room of the Royal
Society if it sounds like something that
might be interesting to you check out
the link on the screen or in the video
description